in this capsule we will see how to comment
what can be formulated a problem of
search in a grace so we
would like to do is solve a
problem by avoiding enumerating all
possible solutions one after the other
others have actually preferred to go through
this list implicitly but so
more effective by actually browsing
while exploring a number of solutions
reduced rather than looking at the number
possible solutions
exponentially high and so the
we are going to take is that we are going
formulate our problem as a premium
search in a serious or check
is going to be a state of my environment
in which my agent can move
each of the links between dummies in
correspond to actions that my
agent can take and in the end
finally a path between two levels
corresponding series of actions for that
the beach you can follow to pass a
initial state to an end state so for
solve that kind of problem there we go
invoke research agriates in
a graph
it was water take in input
firstly an initial null
so the initial state of our age at a
purpose but our goal hate that goes
return true if the goal is reached at
the state or not n would also have a
transition function transition n which
will turn the list where all of our
successors to a null data input n
would also have a function that's who
takes two arguments n
and as a bonus it's a function that goes
to be strictly positive so what
is returned it's a real strictly
positive and who will we return the shot
to move from one channel to honor between
so that will allow us to consider
variable costs in our actions
between our different states so of
move from different menus to others
we are what our algorithm is going
give out is a field
but in a graffiti is so a sequence
of art and craft is an initiative r
a place that satisfies purpose so they
return true when applying the
gaulle function to this final draw 2 and
finally the cost of a path is going
to be the sum of the edges and we wait
too much that can have multiple stages
end who can the bus function or
gaulle can return true for
several of us different an algorithm
search in a graph actually one
can use it for different things
we can first be interested
only to what we need to turn
a path to a solution
what we will, however, often want
it's that not only is it the way
to the solution but in addition the way
getting his revenge - which minimize the
sum of the costs associated with the edges or
in fact sometimes we will be interested in
see a solution but have a
solution as quickly as possible
so we're ready maybe will be ready to
sacrifice the optimality of the found path
to get a solution so that our
talent grid runs faster he
return a solution faster
so here's an example of problems
that could be formulated as a
search problem in a graph
so let's imagine we have several cities
in a road network that we want
determine which path is the most
short between two cities well in this case
also to formulate this problem as a
search problem in a graph
would start with a city hall cities
of our network and to each city we
would associate topless in our case
so n 0 it would be a node associated with
a first city another city and in
then it stops them in our graph
who will connect the two together that's going
match to make paths of
roads between each of these cities
so we ask ourselves here that there is a way
we can take for
to pass from the city
zero to the city
also determine what is our
initial city of our departure city
from which one wishes to make
our our trajectory for
return to our destination city
destination city in this case
will be
m6 the cost associated with transitions between
the vines which is illustrated here that's it
will then match the function c is
what correspond to them
let's say the distance makes it all the time
that it takes two past of 1,013 if in
makes the least long way if we
wants to measure it in terms of time
course
it could also be desired
take the shortest way in term
from distance that to be rather a shot
formulated as a distance
in kilometers for example is finally
see our transition function who she
will give the information on what are
the cities that are directly
directly accessible from
other cities via a path where a
route so for example for l0 but in
our problem we will assume that one
route that directly connects 1 0 or
city ​​n1 n2 and n3 for saïfi good in a
true network tools in fact we would have
probably arts she will come back
that is, a road parliament not
one-way
and we could take the same route
to go into this example 6 2 1 0 1 3
or 3 0 but for this exemption does not
simplified formerly in a
direction that allowed us to
get closer to 1.6 just to simplify
but in practice we could have
connections in both directions plus the
two would probably have the same shot
when a cost of 2.6 is
exactly the same route but with two
different ways and finally our
goal function that will determine if one
has achieved another goal that we have
returned to our destination it's a
function that will return true if the
end node for which we evaluate the
purpose function matches or instead of
destination know m6 in the final and so
so here you see in
the graffiti illustration we have
the information the necks when
we have the cities the stops that
correspond to roads that connects
the cities the cost that's right at
above that corresponds to the associated costs
to move from one city to another than this
either land measure or a measure of
distance according to our problem is safe
this structure we are going to be
possible to run an algorithm of
search in a serious way to find
what is the path that allows with the
minimum cost of this round 2 es10 to es16
and so find the way the most
short between our city associated with 1 0
and our city associated with m6 so that's
the kind of structure or the kind of
problem that I will be able to give to
solve to search algorithms
be serious
there are several types of flu from
search in a serious some of which
you already know there is looking
without ristic and uniformly shot like the
in-depth research or in English
depp
fairsearch so that's the type of
research that will explore children in
first before exploring their brothers
on the contrary we could have a
in-depth search puff for
search that will rather explore the whole
brothers of a knot before exploring
their children and that's so
fertilizers that do not use hardy
and who in fact does not handle the existence
of a variable cost of dinars is to
the other equally unpleasant of
research that are sometimes without rustic
but at variable costs that allow
to integrate the concept of variable cost
between the different do not know
probably the astra algorithm that
actually allows to find the path of
more than a source safe place
and all the others us so it's a
algorithm that could use for
find among other things the most
short between 1 initial node 1 is a
destination but in this one we go
actually focus on research
with rustic that will also be able to
deal with variable costs
two relatively simple algorithms
we will see very quickly if the bret
best for search and the gray deeper search
and the one we're going to spend more
quickly to more time not good it's
the star algorithm and we can in
does that drink the stars grita like
a way to improve the cure of dice
3 to find the path between a mini
heaven and a final goal and its
improvements his accelerations there are going
be obtained through incorporation
of a nurse tic in the procedure of
research